I think everybody knows of Leonardo da
Vinci as the universal man the typical
Renaissance man interest in all
different subject matter but I hope the
anatomical drawings in the totality give
people an understanding that Leonardo
was not simply an artist who dabbled in
the sciences that his scientific pursued
too somehow as a bizarre or or curious
side issue but that his scientific
studies were central to his activity and
that the anatomical drawings in
particular are of such quality and such
sustained brilliance in some ways that
Leonardo deserves to be thought of as
one of the great scientists of the
Renaissance at least the equal of his
status as a painter
this is one of the largest and most
detailed of Leonardo's anatomical
drawings it was compiled around 1509
essentially as a compilation of all his
understanding of the human viscera based
primarily on dissection of man who
claimed to be hundred years old that
Leonardo carried out a couple of years
before and you can see several of the
elements from the dissection of that
centenarian he probably had cirrhosis of
the liver and you see there's an
enlarged spleen the hepatic vessels are
unusually prominent and the umbilical
vein has opened up due to portal
hypertension the heart he showed me
though only two chambers Leonardo's
great investigation of the heart where
he discovered the atria that still to
come the aortic arch is probably bovine
is too symmetrical for the human it
shows that Leonardo was still reliant to
some degree on animal dissection you can
also see that down here in these huge
ligaments that extend from the uterus
sideways which typically bovine rather
than human but if you look closely at
the uterus you can see it's got seven
chambers which was traditionally
believed passed down from from from
Aristotle so within this one drawing
Leonardo is trying to crowd an enormous
amount of information but it's just a
staging post on his on his road to a
full understanding of the human form
throughout his career Leonardo intended
to publish his anatomical research as an
illustrated treatise on human anatomy
but at his death in 1519 all his
anatomical papers remained amongst his
private studio possessions and they were
essentially lost from sight so Leonardo
whereas he could and should have been
one of the great figures in the history
of anatomy is essentially just a
footnote around 1600 about 600 of
Leonardo's surviving drawings were bound
together in a single album and by 6090
it was in the Royal Collection we don't
know how he came into the collection
there's no documents but we think it was
during the reign of Charles a second
as a great artist Leonardo had two
advantages over his contemporary and
atomists first of all as a sculptor
engineer architect he had an intuitive
understanding of form when he dissected
a body he could understanding of in a
very fluid way how the different parts
of the body fitted together how they
work together and then having made that
understanding as a supreme draft and he
was able to record his observations and
discoveries in drawings of such lucidity
he's able to get across the form the
structure to the viewer in a way which
had never been done before
and in many cases has never been
surpassed since
this is one of the sheets of studies
resulting from a campaign of dissection
that Leonardo carried out in the winter
of 1510 probably at the University of
Pavia just to the south of Milan where
he is reported as having collaborated
with a young professor of anatomy there
Marcantonio della Torre and the results
can be seen on a page such as this which
is dense with detail he studies the
muscles of the shoulder and arm the
structure of the hand you see here the
nerves and the arteries feeding into the
hand and here at the centre of the sheet
an amazingly sophisticated dissection of
the muscles of the face and this is very
very difficult to dissect and Leonardo
has got it almost perfectly correctly it
can identify every single muscle now the
drawings are surrounded by this
patchwork of notes in these is partly
explaining the drawings on the page but
also setting himself further topics that
he wanted to investigate their sheets
done for Leonardo's own record they're
not intended for anybody else to see and
consequently he wrote in mirror image
with the left hand from right to left
with every word and letter in perfect
more image throughout his life it was
simply easier for him I think as a
left-hander if we turn the sheet over
because this is a sheet from a notebook
that Leonardo compiled drawings and
notes on both sides you can see
Leonardo's most comprehensive study of
the skeleton he's treated it almost like
an architectural drawing with three
elevations mutually orthogonal angles
from the front from the back from the
side
Leonardo's last and in many ways his
finest campaign of anatomical
investigation was into the structure of
the heart working mainly with Roxy's
heart he D secta dit - extraordinarily
fine level of detail and the sheet of
study as you see here is an
investigation of the functioning of the
aortic valve now they're not I realize
that at the root of the aorta was the
slight swelling a lot of chamber which
we now call the sinus of valsalva and he
wanted to investigate the function of
this so he injected molten wax into the
aorta and it certainly could see this
bulb shape when he detected it away and
then he made a glass model around that
wax cast and he shows it in
cross-section here
and then he could pump water with a
suspension of grass seeds through his
glass model and observe these vortices
in the sinus immediately both the aortic
valve and he deduced that these vortices
played a crucial role in the opening out
to the cusps of the valve after each
pump of the heart and it's absolutely
right it's only in the 20th century that
cardiologists basically agreed with
Leonardo that the vortices in the sinus
about Alba are crucial for the function
of the order it's it's the most
incredibly sophisticated piece of
Investigation and shows Leonardo as an
experimental scientist at absolute best